prime minister you've been in power for
28 days but 10 of those politics was
paused in 18 days then you announced 45
billion pounds of tax cuts without
setting a fiscal framework it
precipitated a 65 billion emergency Bond
buying program by the bank of England to
protect Pension funds the pound Tanked a
thousand mortgage deals withdrawn from
the markets as interest rate rates
expectations spiked you established a
33-point lead for labor in the polls and
now the lady not for turning has
announced a massive u-turn on a policy
this is surely the worst start of any
prime minister well let's remember what
we were facing four weeks ago but do you
expect we were facing we were facing
families having energy bills of up to
six thousand pounds we were facing
inflation that could have been five
percent higher as a result of those
Energy prices and we were facing a
global economic slowdown and what we
have done as a government is acted
decisively we've acted to put in place
the energy price guarantee which has
already come in it means that families
typical family won't be paying more than
around 2 500 pounds
my question was do you accept you've had
a rocky start well what I am saying is
that we have acted decisively in the
face of very very difficult
International circumstances where Putin
has been perpetrating the war in Ukraine
that has caused an energy I'm going to
have to because I haven't got very long
and I've got so many questions for you
let me put it another way do you think
your personal Authority has been
enhanced or reduced in your short time
in office what I have done is I have
delivered in very difficult
circumstances for the British people
people were worried that they would
struggle with fuel bills this winter
people were worried if you remember that
they would be struggling with their
energy bills that businesses would go
out of business we have dealt with that
issue we had to act quickly we had to do
that mini budget in the circumstances to
be able to deal with slowing economic
growth and with energy
you've had a bad start and you don't
accept that your leadership has been
troubled in the start of your
Premiership just to be clear you don't
accept that question I've always been
very clear and I was clear during the
leadership election that we are facing
very tough economic times and it would
be difficult and we would have to make
difficult decisions and we would have
said you'd stick to decisions and you
use hand
well what I did is I took the decision
very rapidly on the 45p rate that it was
becoming a distraction from the core
policies we were delivering core
policies on the energy price guarantee
on keeping taxes low during the economic
slowdown those were the priorities
frankly the 45p wasn't a priority policy
and I listened to people and I think
there's there's absolutely no shame Beth
in a leader listening to people and
responding and that's the kind of person
I am and I've been totally honest and
upfront with people but it everything
I've done as prime minister is focused
on helping people get through what is a
very difficult winter and very difficult
circumstances and putting our country on
a stronger footing in the future that
that is what I think about that is you
say you listen but don't you remember
being warned
well I hear all kinds of you know advice
and warnings and you know people people
are suggesting what what should be done
what we have as a government is a very
is a very what I have is a very clear
plan Richie Suna warned in August that
unfunded spending commitments could
force up inflation and interest rates
and increase borrowing costs Rishi was
right wasn't he and many Tories look at
the wreckage of the first month and
think that they chose the wrong person
well I don't agree with that analysis
because the energy price guarantee
package we put in is actually expected
to reduce inflation
is still double digits and you've got to
be worried it's expected to reduce
inflation by up to Five Points what we
know and the this is being corroborated
independently what we know is the
package we're putting in is deflation
rate okay prime minister it seems to me
that there is a bit of a crisis of lead
ship for you already at the heart of
this it's not just former cabinet
ministers like Gove Patel Sharps
criticizing policies forcing you to a
U-turn it's loyalists too Nadine dory's
a loyalist who backed you a key backer
in your leadership campaign now saying
you don't have a mandate for what you're
trying to do you should go to the
country
that's your that's a loyal that's
someone that backs you
you don't have to be worried about that
what what people want what people want
is a government who is going to deal
with via media issues that we face and
the immediate issue was the very very
high energy bills we've done we've dealt
with that but also help our country get
onto a strong footing and Beth I've
never claimed that this would be easy
I've never claimed that this wouldn't be
tough but we are facing loyalists very
tough these are loyalists these are
people that bat you saying that well you
well she said that you threw the
transfer under the bus fingers fingers
crossed things improve and settle down
that's the loyalist if Liz wants a whole
new mandate she must take it to the
country that's Nadine Doris I mean the
public will see that and think wow if
the prime minister's backers don't back
her anymore we're in trouble what I'm
thinking about every day is how to
deliver for people in these tough
circumstances and we Face these huge
challenges which other countries face to
you have lost control haven't you and
that's why you head to Utah and you've
lost control of your party we made the
decision we made the decision on the
force you couldn't get it and also
because of the reaction of the public
acceptance because you couldn't get it
through then
I took feedback and I listened from the
public and from the party
it wasn't a core part of our package
what I am focused on is delivering
people on energy because you couldn't
get it through the background delivering
on taxes well you told you couldn't get
it through the back benches Beth you're
asking me about a decision we've already
made a policy that we're no longer
because it matters I'm asking you
because it matters because if you want
to run the country you have to be able
to get votes through Parliament so you
need your MPS to back you that's why
what the leadership is about what my
leadership is about is doing the right
thing delivering for people who are
struggling with their energy bills
delivering for businesses who want to
invest in this country because
ultimately what I'm about is about
getting to a stronger United Kingdom
that is a high wage country and that
will take
difficult decisions just one more
question the policy decided by the last
Prime is to upgrade benefits with
inflation you don't seem minded to do
that we haven't made a decision on that
issue my priorities so you decide I mean
you you seem not you're the Prime
Minister you said you're going to up
rate pensions by inflation you're the
Prime Minister I'm saying to you you
don't see minded to do that we haven't
made a decision on that issue yet well
you could decide now yes I've decided I
think it should be uplifted by inflation
well I can assure you that any
announcement would be made to Parliament
uh not on Sky well you you made the
announcement on the pensions uplift not
to Parliament and you the triple lock
well that was a commitment that we made
in our manifest well there's lots of
commitments in muscles I think voters
are just tired of the lack of honest
answers I'm just saying to you're not
minded to do it I've been very honest
about the challenges we Face I've been
very honest about about the solutions
including the energy price guarantee
keeping taxes low getting our economy
going getting things like roads built
that's what I'm focused on of course we
will make the decision on the benefits
operating in due course but that
decision has not yet been made what you
what you want to do or you just you're
generally ambivalent I'm not ambivalent
I am focused on the issue at hand which
has been sorting out the energy crisis
making sure we're putting the UK on a
firmer footing making sure we're getting
our economy growing that's what I've
been focused on Final question I've run
out of time do you have a mortgage
I do and you have an issue about
remortgaging
well I
I mean I I do have a mortgage yes the
reason I'm asking you is that lots of
people are now facing a spike in
interest rates and if you have to
remortgage on a variable rate you could
be facing hundreds of pounds on
additional costs so I'm just asking you
is this as prime minister something
you're personally having to think about
as well
the issue of interest rates is we have
had historically low interest rates for
a number of years I understand people
are concerned and worried what we are
seeing globally is we are seeing a rise
in interest rate so the Federal Reserve
the bank in America has put up its
interest rates ultimately interest rates
are a matter for the bank of England
they're not decided by politicians and I
think that's the right approach okay
promise thank you thank you thank you